[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here we will discuss the dragon dreams
of Princess Helena Targaryen and what
are their significance so what are
Dragon dreams well these are sort of
like prophetic and predictive dreams
that certain people experience in the
world of A Song of Ice and Fire they are
reported to have premonition like dream
abilities they frequently but not always
involve Dragons Dragon dreams appear to
have trouble individuals with dragon
blood for Generations showing signs of
things yet to come but in a cryptic way
so they are mostly undeciphered but only
makes sense when the events come to pass
these have been mainly experienced by
the targaryens and the black fires
some of the notable Dragon dreamers are
as follows the first one is Dana's the
dreamer who was an ancestor of aegon the
Conqueror she dreamed about the fall and
the Doom of valyria and as such her
father sold all his belongings in
valyria and moved to Dragonstone thus
saving the entire bloodline even aegon
the Conqueror had Dragon dreams that
foreshadowed The Long Winter and the
second coming of the white walkers hence
bringing to light the prophecy of Azor
ahai and The Song of Ice and Fire others
like Deron Damon blackfyre and master
Eamon also had such dreams but were of
no significance until Daenerys who had
quite a few of them and were the main
source of driving her to conquer the
Seven Kingdoms again only to end in her
demise
so now let's get to the topic at hand
although there was no description of
Princess Helena as a dreamer in the
books in the series however she was
portrayed as such she was first seen as
a shy character lost in her own world
speaking in riddles and often in the
company of spiders and bugs she was
first portrayed as a quiet quirky
character but in episode 8 she blossomed
into her own brand of delightful humor
she already had children by this time a
pair of twins jahiris and Jahira but she
also had prophetic Visions which come
and go without her control and here are
three of them along with their
explanations
let's start with the first prophecy
you will have a dragon one day he'll
have to close an eye after being
discovered in the dragon pit and upset
Eamon was escorted to Alison in episode
6. he grumbled about how aegon and
rhaenerys boys made fun of him of not
having a dragon yet Helena was playing
with her insects as Eamonn screamed to
his mother Helena then mumbled to
herself when Alison assured Eamon that
he would have a dragon she said he'll
have to lose an eye these words
prophesies that in order to claim vegar
Eamon would have to lose one of his eyes
which came true after a fight with the
other youngsters after he wrote Vega
now coming to the second prophecy
rule of Green School of black dragons
flesh weaving dragons thread
seven during the funeral of Lena
valarion Helena uttered these words when
she was playing with a spider this
vision would be of great significance as
it foreshadows the upcoming War the ham
turns Loom which means that the hand of
the king is the one who is behind all
the chaos and infighting the spools of
green and spools of black meaning the
green faction which are Alison's side
while the blacks are those of rhaenerys
dragons of flesh meaning the targaryens
and their dragons weaving dragons of
thread meaning calling out their
loyalists under their own banners both
banners that showed the Targaryen emblem
the tree had a dragon woven in thread
and now lastly for the third prophecy
there is a beast beneath
she added these words in both episode 8
and episode 9. her first warning
occurred during the family supplement
episode 8 just as Jays ended his toes to
aegon and Eamon and her second came in
episode 9 as her mother was ready to
inform her of the services death
Helena's prophecy about the Beast under
the boat might refer to reynus and her
Dragon the bees crashing through the
floor of the Dragon pit as aegon's
coronation took place in episode 9. or
it might also mean the growing tensions
between their families as well as it
might be as insignificant as aegon
hiding beneath a table when the Cargill
twins was sent to find him aegon being
the Beast that would start the war due
to his reluctant coronation
so will Helena change the colors of the
war well it seems that the high towers
and her brothers don't really realize
what kind of gift she has and even her
husband aegon describes her as an idiot
Queen Allison however seems to be the
only one showing any signs of sympathy
and interest in her well first because
she is her daughter but seems to be lost
when Helena starts to speak in riddles
this is one such Folly that the greens
will come to regret as they do not
consider the power of the Dragon dreams
that she has and how it might have
charted at different goals of actions in
the dance of the Dragons so subscribe
hit that notification button and take
care fam